this week we're talking about encryption
migrating legacy were closed in
kubernetes I'm Carter Morgan and welcome
to this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news cloud computing
is certainly the new standard but the
complexity cost and risk of a cloud
migration may be holding your business
back bare-metal solution is designed to
bridge this gap by offering hardware
that supports enterprise applications
with a dedicated connection of Google
cloud it's time for a cloud solution
that works for specialized legacy
workloads as part of our non-stop push
for security we're updating the external
key manager which allows businesses to
maintain separation between their
encrypted data and the keys of that
encryption we're also introducing key
access justifications to provide a
detailed justification each time an
external encryption key is requested
with these two services you are the
ultimate arbiter of your data there's
always more work to be done and scaling
that work is a constant challenge but
for google kubernetes engine we've
become the preview of batch a cloud
native solution for running batch
workloads at scale in an optimized
manner try it out and then let us know
what you think
seriously the product team wants you to
email them your thoughts and questions
and speaking of kubernetes cloud code is
now generally available developers can
write debug and deploy code to google
cloud or any kubernetes cluster and if
you missed the features of your
preferred ide
there's an extension for that if you
want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us I'm Carter
Morgan and we'll see you in the cloud
you